[Music]
hey
everybody yeah what's up uh yeah we just
had to like start a new stream because
uh it's storming outside and i lost my
connection before i started
so you know yeah this new uh computer it
restarts a lot faster too so we
restarted some [ __ ] and then just uh
did a new stream it tried to reconnect
it was having problems
but we had the thunder strike just a few
seconds before all this [ __ ] happened so
i probably had some do it i would
imagine yeah because this the weather's
been kind of bad all day today
so you know not that i mind that i kind
of like i kind of like working in here
and hearing all the thunder and [ __ ]
outside
yeah we're drinking black velvet yeah we
don't usually do this on the show in the
middle of the afternoon but
yeah decided to have a beer had that on
sale it was a
wicked grove that was like some [ __ ]
they had it all these
it's like angry orchards yeah wicked
grove is
angry altogether and then got some
[ __ ] guinness guinness stout
that's pretty good yeah and look i love
the i love the bottle cap because i get
excited about like little stuff like
this but i love the bottle cap for
wicked growth look it's a little
yeah a little mad apple
put a couple by a beer mug
got them wet put them in the freezer
yeah we have frosty mugs and everything
we're just in planning head i didn't
even know you had that in there
i had them ready we're ready to go
everybody's saying i'm in here a couple
days ago
everybody's saying happy birthday to you
they should they should probably wait
until
it's not my birthday wait until the
wednesday night show because your
birthday is on thursday
yeah so that'll probably that's like the
closest to yours
yeah he doesn't care no i really don't
care what my birthday is
he doesn't want to think about it
speaking of which
tammy sent this hilarious yeah yeah here
uh she sent this hilarious [ __ ] card
yesterday yes chick with big boobs on it
yeah a birthday aging quiz with like
yeah look at her go she looks kind of
like
yeah i passed that i i failed that
[ __ ] question well that's kind of the
failed
yeah because it's like a birthday agent
quiz and then it's like what color is
her purse
right yeah i even see the damage but to
be honest i didn't even notice she has a
shadow purse either so you know she sent
me that whole bunch of money
if you said she had a purse you're still
young or you're taking your hormones
says tammy so thank you very much for
that also yeah she said a bunch of body
and look
she put it in this piece of paper that
says look it says
flash bulbs
[Laughter]
and that was the best part i thought she
also wanted a shirt i got your order
we'll send it out to you yeah we're
actually uh i should
be getting the last of the shirts i the
the blank shirts that i ordered today so
we'll probably print them tomorrow
probably print them up tomorrow and send
them out and send them out
tammy said wow it got there fast yeah
yeah
that was pretty cool it was funny i was
laughing it was really early
yeah like i did that flash bulbs thing
just like maybe like i was laughing at
the boobs
as soon as i took that [ __ ] out i was
starting to take a laugh that was funny
too
i said she's trying to pull my [ __ ]
heart strings but what
although like i said boobs are bigger
than most girls
you have boobs they got girls [ __ ]
paying good money for [ __ ] like this
although like i said to be fair i didn't
notice that she had a purse either yeah
right
you know yeah so you know what i mean
yeah jenny's got boob greed also
i don't know if it's so much boob greed
it's just they're kind of like all
they're it's up in your face and you're
right and her and her purse was kind of
like blended into the background you
know when i looked at it
what color was that yeah tom sees no
purse
i didn't see the background i didn't
even see what color her hair was and
just look at the damn boobs you know
it's yeah it's blunt it's just [ __ ]
an inborn
instinct that some men have you know
what i mean some guys
it's boobs boobs and [ __ ]
shoes you know i don't know this is why
i could probably just say whatever and
you wouldn't listen because you'd be too
busy like looking at my boobs
and yeah yeah whatever i sound like
charles charlie brown's mom
she's [ __ ] that's not that it's not
that bad
not quite it's not quite that bad i can
resist it
[Laughter]
all right so let's just talk about this
movie for a few
moments hopefully the storm doesn't uh
knock any of our [ __ ] out a bunch of
thunder here
uh so this is one like i said i read
about this one a few months back
and uh i was just like oh tom will
probably dig that just from the brief
description that i saw and the fact that
it was set in uh brazil and it was in
portuguese
yeah and uh you know you kind of you
tend to like kind of more like
over-the-top kind of action-packed kind
of stuff so i was like well that sounds
kind of like something that would be
along you know the lines of something
you would like for people who
um are new to the show i grew up in sao
paulo brazil
after i left uh california back in uh
like he was 81
so i did all my high school time and
early half of my high school time in
brazil
and uh i think my parents were there for
12 years
i was only there i think for a total of
like four or five
you know something like that but he
still speaks uh
he's still talking the guys i grew up
with and so i'm following and he didn't
need the when we watched the movie last
night he didn't
really need it it took me a few minutes
to [ __ ] make that adjustment i
haven't heard it in a while
now this is the second brazilian
horror movie that we've seen recently
this one was good and so was uh
that other one that was what was that
called ghost killers versus bloody berry
yeah yeah that one was more like goofy
than this one this one was kind of more
this had
yeah this was gorier i think yeah but
it would had a little bit more of a
serious kind of thing even though it had
some goofy [ __ ] in it but it wasn't as
over the top goofy yeah it was
you know there's there's some there's
some parody a little bit in both of them
you know uh they're just parroting
different things [ __ ] ghost
uh what was it ghost killers [ __ ]
bloody mary
that one just parodied everything it was
almost kind of like scream
but it was also it also had uh
some some good [ __ ] in it too like they
they really knew
american horror genre but they were
parroting the american horrors out of
the 80s
this one also it's parroting
brazilian horror genre of the
late 70s in the early 80s the motif of
this movie
is very okay brazil had an
italian influence in its culture so
italian filmmaking and things like
giallo giallo also kind of
influenced brazil's yeah this totally
had a bit of a jello
going on for sure their cinema
their cinema more copy what was
happening in italy okay
um which makes sense if you understand
brazil i mean uh the braz
brazil has a very heavy italian
influence into it you know
it's it's a romance culture it's wrong
it's a italy was a big part of it
you know but uh yeah
i mean just the way it's shot that
they're kind of like artificially aiming
aging the film it does flashbacks and
does weird things like you're watching
it
on an old worn out [ __ ] brazilian
[ __ ] projector you know i mean it's
just if you if you had grown up in
brazil
in the 80s you instantly recognize the
tone of what they're doing
and it's difficult for me to to describe
it to an american
it's a weird movie but it was also kind
of like
there were parts of it that were sort of
slow but it was also like kind of
parts of it were like inspired and like
there were a few parts of it where like
some of it happened i'm like okay this
movie is officially awesome right now
yeah it starts in the 1940s in a
flashback
of some [ __ ] that happened in brazil
between nazis
and cults and
i guess some kind of a um
a cult that protects the world against
the forces of evil that's in it too
and it's funny because it has elements
of like kung fu movies
and uh italian
uh cannibal movies you know like the
cannibal holocaust
a little bit yeah the way the look and
what they're trying to do is kind of
like that
which if you were
like me and my brazilian friends growing
up in brazil
they were just getting into the vhs
thing too in the in
in the early 80s and video rental they
didn't have chains they had like mon paw
video rental stores
and you could get these old [ __ ]
italian horror movies like zombie and
[ __ ] like that and all the american ones
and
we all watched the same movies except in
brazil they kind of added some european
ones in it too
because they didn't care where the movie
came from i mean they were all subtitled
anyway
you had to read subtitles yeah it didn't
matter if it come from america or not
and it's in this movie you can see the
influences of it i really liked what
they were doing
the score is very good oh yeah i really
don't
yeah a lot of it takes place in sao
paulo and it started taking me back to
sao paulo and they're
showing it like in the shitty areas or
something well there were some in the
nice area
some of it was in a nice area a lot of
it was in the shitty areas
but that fit the story you know there's
uh
there's a lot of um influence from like
american stuff too kind of like the
exorcist and
a lot of friday the 13th there's a g
yeah i was gonna say there's like a 80s
uh slasher movie vibe to it too but
there's also like a noir
giallo type of because there's a
detective yeah
and then there's also like supernatural
kind of [ __ ] too because it's almost
like a possession type thing going on
also brazilian gothic lesbians in it
there's all kinds of just one they're
just one yeah and her
her older wife and it's super super gory
yeah i mean this uh this premiered i
think
at least in the u.s at the chattanooga
film festival last year
yeah which they did virtually because
like i said because of uh the shutdown
so uh and it got a reputation this movie
got a reputation for being just like
you know insanely gory yeah and it's
practical gore
yeah and it looks like old italian gore
pretty good i liked it
it's kind of a throwback but then it
breaks into these cosmic scenes
oh those were super cool what's
happening in in in
in in the spirit world because you're
dealing with a
like a a pre-columbian mesoamerican
demonic
being and you see what's happening over
there and it looked really cool
and it it looked kind of like a the
motif was like
kind of like blood machines but if the
blood machines was taking place in the
70s or something
it looked pretty cool that was super
cool when they when they went to that
so you could say that it's kind of like
um
i saw a couple reviews of it like on
some different horror sites
and like uh most of them like really
liked it but they said you know some of
it's kind of all over the place or it
seems like two or three different movies
yeah kind of like all mashed together
yeah but that's which
that's fair um but that said
i still like enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it
yeah you know i thought it was a lot of
fun
the story is kind of ponderous by
americans
yes it kind of goes all over the place
but that's very much in the old
traditions of old brazilian
cinema they were like that too they had
plenty of time that you know the
audience weren't going anywhere it's
kind of like italian cinema
they'd go all over the [ __ ] place
and and they're homaging that in this
movie though that was done on purpose
because the other brazilian film that we
saw
homaged american 80s horror and they got
that edit down perfectly that's exactly
the way 80s i mean yeah and
retro horror was and it almost they
could do it it's just it kind of
parodied like ghost hunting shows
yeah as well yeah it did that one yeah i
recommend both of them brazilian
those two brazilian horror movies are
kind of
um delivering they delivered um
the bloody mary was kind of like kind of
like the
the frighteners of the brazilian movies
this one would be kind of like
[ __ ] this would be like a giallo movie
this one's brazilian
except i don't know it's really hard to
explain
imagine if friday the 13th was a giallo
movie
made in italy but it's brazil and
there's cosmic horror mixed in with it
and it's kind of like lovecraft
and also there are nazis and they're
nazis and there's a rambo type guy in it
it's
it's and they're it's just
it they are [ __ ] with you you're not
supposed to be taking this 100
seriously you're supposed to just enjoy
it you know in the way that you know
like you would enjoy a [ __ ] crazy
italian movie
it's like that yeah it definitely did
give me that kind of like italian
exploitation yeah
yeah um it definitely has that and like
i said the gore looks fantastic
people's heads explode uh people get
their hearts ripped out there's rib
cages
busting all over the place yeah the
demon is a mask that looks like a skull
that
[ __ ] legs come out of it like a
spider it attacks you like tentacles
it's kind of like
kind of like something like an alien and
then it gets on your head and you can't
get it off and you turn into jason
and he's got a [ __ ] like a
mesoamerican foot kind of like an aztec
[ __ ] weapon but it's made out of iron
instead of obsidian
and all kinds of weird [ __ ] happens he's
got to fight all these people and every
time he
kills somebody it fills up a damn kind
of [ __ ] mechanism to unlock it
it's it's complicated and then yeah the
story is kind of complicated yeah
one one of the main characters is she's
a cop and she's basically kind of like
the brazilian scarlett johansson she
looks
a lot like she looks like eerily like
scarlett johansson
yeah if scarlett johansson was like was
brazilian
yeah she would if she was like latina
brazilian like portuguese just said
what she looks like and uh it's it was a
cool flick i liked it
i liked it i liked it a lot too set up
sequels
did we even mention it's called skull
the mask
the mask basically like like i said what
you have the mask was like a skull
well it was a skull and it was a i think
it's called something different in
portuguese actually i think it's still
called skull
but then it has like a different
subtitle it's called the mask of
uh anhanga or whatever they called it
that was the name of the because this is
going
pre-columbian yeah [ __ ] here because
like at the very beginning it's almost
kind of like you're watching an old film
strip
of nazis and they found this artifact
right which is the skull
yeah and they kind of were doing some
sort of ritual with it or something yeah
and then we're not talking about
nazis in the german europe phase we're
talking about
the nazis that escaped germany and ended
up in
in brazil and in argentina that the suit
wearing nazis
living out in the country that's what
they're talking about yeah
yeah south american nazis so then
there's a thing there's kung fu
uh someone's head explodes someone's
hand gets cut off and then we're jumping
ahead to the present day
2021 and um
somebody like i guess somebody at a uh
construction company has
found the skull like so they take it
like first so somebody comes to like
collect it because it's an
archaeological
uh you know find and everything and then
there's a dude
that works for who was that dude does he
work for like a company like a museum or
something the creepy looking dude that
looked kind of like
uh jeffrey combs from yeah he was um
kind of like the head of some kind of
cult that was
trying to get all these evil artifacts
yeah because there was that whole thing
because the whole thing
with that is going on and then the
woman that went and got the skull she
brings it home
to her house and her girlfriend
um who's kind of like a gothy wiccan
kind of chick it's just kind of like oh
i want to see what this is and she's
like no no it's
you know i have to take to the museum
tomorrow and i'll [ __ ] with it but of
course she does [ __ ] with it
and she's like oh i'm going to like
[ __ ] summon some [ __ ] and she
summoned some [ __ ] and like everyone's
heart gets ripped out
and meanwhile there's this detective
who's looking for these missing girls
which actually does kind of play into
the story later on it does kind of all
tie together
and then also there's a dude named manco
who is sort of like there's him and
there's like this priest that he's
always talking to
manko has this little hand that
i guess was the hand from the dude at
the beginning and it kind of points to
where the skull is at
yeah there was like a monkey's paw
situation something right
that guy was trying to um get the mask
away from him wasn't he and he got
caught
he was like one of the old yeah he was
from some kind of like secret society
you're right and they were supposed to
watch over the [ __ ] because
if somebody got the skull and knew how
to use it
like it'd be really really bad because
it was like this cosmic like i said when
the first one the girl
um first summons the demon
or whatever um i guess what it was when
i looked at the wikipedia page
so i guess the mask belongs to what
how'd you what did you say with the
guy's name was the
mask of whatever now i i am god yeah
so he's so that guy is the executioner
of a pre-columbian god named
tahan tusupe something like that i'm
just not even gonna burn it to pronounce
but
i think they just called him taha yeah
uh in the movie but that's
what it is so this guy is just going
around
randomly killing [ __ ] and
tearing their hearts out and like
squeezing the blood and everything
yeah he's like jason yeah and he gets
well the more the longer you wear the
mask like the more it becomes integrated
and you start coming quits and like i
said the skulls
start coming yeah the skull has like
tentacles like these little things like
coming out of his head and they feel
like tentacles and
it's all practical effects it looks like
something out of the 80s
i mean well done i think because they
showed in the cosmic
horror type scenes in the other
dimension that brazil
has at least now or either has access to
studios that can
execute or they buy stuff from they can
do real good cg
when they want to they're just trying to
show you practical effects like you grew
up with as a kid this is
this is a throwback movie definitely you
know and the gore in this is great i had
a
i had a great time with like yeah it
looked italian it looked like italian
yes so if you like seeing everyone's
broken rib cages sticking out
people like just punching like through
people's chests and pulling their hearts
out
people's heads exploding [ __ ] like that
it's super super fun
yeah and then there's like i said
there's a lot of kind of the detective
[ __ ] going on too
and all of this sort of scheming
everyone trying to get this mask
and meanwhile the person that had put
the mask on running around being
like jason and like chopping everybody
up um so there's that a whole thing
going on
like i said it seems like two or three
different movies going on at once but
that's okay
i didn't mind it they're homaging
brazilian cinema yeah of the past and uh
just like we do you know yeah and it's
it's um
the acting was very good uh
tonally it's all over the place but it's
kind of supposed to be
some of the characters are obviously you
know in there for laughs and gags
their comedic relief they have that some
of them are serious kind of dramatic
roles
the main bad guy is kind of almost like
a jeffrey combs
doing [ __ ] lieutenant danvers you
know detective danvers from [ __ ]
you know uh the brainerd the frighteners
yeah he's kind of like that a little bit
not quite as over top as combs but
similar um it's just it's just a good
flick
it's a good flick um i would call it
cinema
not commercial at all no because
brazilian
classic brazilian cinema was not
commercial it was
art house basically um
brazilians were going to watch that [ __ ]
no matter what because it was made in
brazil
yeah because you know the it was like
italy you know i mean everybody went to
the movies
didn't cost much anyway yeah so you know
cable eventually got rid of it took a
long time for brazil to get that
you know and uh so no they're just
imagine what the state of brazilian
cinema was
the 70s and 80s it was good i kind of
like it looked like i don't know if it
was actually shot on
film but it looks like it was shot on
film it looked like it
because it looks like a movie that was
made back then i don't know if they just
artificially made it look like that it's
hard to tell i think they did
um and some of this stuff's happening in
2020 or 2021. pretty much all of it has
happened in
20 yeah and it still looks like it was
back in the 70s yeah so like i said
even like cinematically it looks like
right like an old exploitation movie
which i dug that
yeah because that's kind of like varus
and military right there they're trying
to make it look like a movie from back
then
it fit the setting it fit the story the
tone
of the story and the actors um what i
really liked was the score
uh they did some real cool like jazz
type
yeah brazilian jazz type stuff which is
like
very popular in brazil used to listen to
it you know you're getting drunk looking
at your window look at the cityscape you
show the beautiful
cityscape sao paulo is [ __ ] huge uh
it's got good places and bad places but
you can have fun no matter where you are
there at least it wasn't the time that i
was there
um well you said it's a party town well
you said too that they showed because
they showed like a few like long shots
of the city and you said that you
remembered yeah the city's so big
that it lights up the whole sky lights
up get lights up all the clouds
so you you get this reflection of the
city lights coming from the crowd you
don't need to try you drive around with
that
without headlights you just write
daytime out just markers
yeah you know like your parking markers
if you put your headlights on people
will
blast you with their brights tell you to
turn them off because your night vision
can
has no because it's bright enough it's
bright enough yeah tammy said what is
this on it's on
shutter uh it might be somewhere else as
well
it's weird because like i said i heard
about it a few months ago
uh you know because i said oh it's
brazilian so tom would probably want to
see that
but then when i looked for it back then
i couldn't find it but then
about a month ago shutter added it so at
this point
if shutter has it sometimes amazon prime
has it as well
um so we'll see and sometimes to be has
it as well but i don't know if it's on
tubie yeah but i'm pretty i'm
i'm sure that it's on shutter though
yeah at least in the u.s
um fourth throw down says i think the
thing from 2011 was made to look like it
was made in the 80s
now i'm going to have to go back and
watch that again because i don't
remember seeing it no not
like that i mean that wasn't something
that no it didn't it just
struck me it was it took place in the
80s
before the thing had happened but it was
shot as a modern movie
it was originally going to have um
practical effects in it
but the company that released it and
evidently the practical effects looked
really good
but then the company that owned it cg
over
most of the practical effects doesn't
that sound to make it look more like a
modern movie which is abs
which that's [ __ ] you know i'm not
thank you no need for me to
love the stories from other cultures
that i never experienced tom spends a
good yarn yes
oh yeah thanks yeah i mean and i'm not
[ __ ] on people that do digital
effects because that's an art form of
its own okay i'm not saying that
but taking people that made stuff with
their like monsters and [ __ ] like that
with their hands and like did them all
practical and figured out how to do it
like they did back in the day
and then for them to go through all that
work and then you're like no we're just
gonna like slap some [ __ ] cartoon
over it yeah
and i own the blu-ray thing and it's a
shame they didn't have both versions
so you could see the the the cg
theatrical release yeah see i would have
liked to have seen the practical
release i wanted to see what it looked
like to practice because evidently the
practical effects
were going to be like
the whole movie was an homage to the to
the thing
and the practical effects were supposed
to be even better than the thing
so they could like honor it there were
gonna be a practical effect that they
could do that
and what you could what it would look
like today but evidently uh whoever
was running that [ __ ] show said no i
don't really like it
let's make it look like a modern movie
we'll cgi over this
i would have liked to have a choice one
of my favorite things about horror in
the last few years
is that people have really started to
appreciate practical effects again yeah
most indie movies that i've seen lately
at least mostly do practical effects
cg is good for certain certain things
yeah and i'm not [ __ ] on it so you
know and like i said i know there's
people that's good at that it's a
different kind of art form so i would
never say oh it sucks just across the
board because it doesn't
a mixture of the two would be nice but
it's very diff
very difficult to beat really good
practical effects a good a good movie
as an example was a merged merger of
practical and cgi
was fury road yeah it was mostly
which was almost all practical but they
used cg to do things like hire
hide tire tracks and to uh just to raise
suspension
yes and safety stuff that was around
those vehicles which like i don't have a
problem with that at all because you're
still doing the [ __ ] yeah
you know and obviously we don't want
actors getting killed and [ __ ] like that
so yes they do have they should have
safety equipment but when those cars
wrecked
that really was the wreck even even when
the moving
[ __ ] signal vehicle that had all the
[ __ ] band playing on the guitar guy
a lot of people thought that was cg see
that truck um
falling apart and all the speakers
flying off it no it's it that was real
the only thing that wasn't cg was the
only thing that wasn't practical
was when the steering wheel came at the
came with the camera yeah but no
everything else was everything else was
practical it's just that shot in a weird
frame
rate and it was in hd so it kind of
looked fake well even when they flipped
that truck over at the end
yeah and that was uh that was real too
because actually we watched all that
because we have it and we've seen it
like
[ __ ] it a million times all the extras
and we've watched all the extras and
they showed them like
setting all the stunt up and they showed
them doing this like look we can pretty
much only do this one time so i don't
[ __ ] it up
even the guitarist that shot the flames
out of his guitar even that was a real
flamethrower
so yeah we're saying all right the
flames look fake that's cg no that's
real it's real
you could do it just that it had it had
a certain color filter on it to make
that make the flames look really red but
it was real
yep yeah they went they went the
distance with that one yeah mad respect
and there's supposed to be a sequel to
it
i want to see another furiosa movie yeah
i think they should just make a movie
called furiosa and it should be all
about her because she's [ __ ] rad
but you know i don't i don't know if
charlie's there and wants to do it again
but she was [ __ ] great in that i love
that [ __ ] movie so much
but yeah so uh what was i gonna say um
another movie i was gonna i did a review
of it on my uh little flickers of fear
show
but if you like italian giallo movies
you should go watch barbarian sound
studio
because that's another one that was set
during the heyday of giallo movies
and it's not it's like a psychological
horror film but it's kind of like about
a dude
that is um he's doing like the sound
effects
for a giallo movie um and
he's kind of like this really prissy
like english guy and he doesn't
understand like this weird so it's like
this weird like culture clash thing and
it's always
it's really really good but it's kind of
made like the whole look of it is like
really cool too
i really like that like some some uh
filmmakers lately have been making like
some kind of modern giallos or making
things that are kind of
inspired by that yeah well
cinema is gonna have to go back to its
roots and become kind of spontaneous and
are artistic
um even um quentin tarantino came out a
couple days ago and started to [ __ ]
warn hollywood that the movies are
sucking that the stories are sucking and
that
it's got to go back to it its roots
hollywood has to go punk rock basically
it's just it's too corporate
well like i said that's kind of why i
even like
you know when they show because somebody
was saying that like there's some good
movies on shutter and stuff you know
there's a movie on there called
host that was filmed entirely during uh
the pandemic and it was filmed entirely
on
laptops and it's like i actually liked
that movie but even if you didn't
you have to admire like you said the the
punk rock spirit we're gonna make a
movie entirely on [ __ ] laptops
right while everyone's at lockdown these
guys could you know it was like
early on and the fact that they just did
it
i mean that should command respect them
even if it doesn't come out like
as great as they wanted it's like i just
respect them for like
actually wanting to do something like
that and seeing what they can do with it
i think they did the same thing with a
few years back there was a movie called
uh unfriended and they made the whole
thing on a mac laptop like in real time
you know what i mean and it was kind of
like a blair witch situation where they
just had the actors but they're just
kind of like well here's like the random
plot but we're not gonna tell you like
what's gonna happen
and we're not gonna tell you what to do
so it's all like improvised um
and it's actually not a bad film for all
of that uh it actually turned out pretty
good
so i just i kind of like that people are
going back to that that they're going
back to practical effects
yeah um you know making their own
monsters doing blood and [ __ ] like that
and i really like seeing too and
that's one thing that another thing that
i really like about shutter is that they
really seem to try to get
movies from other countries yeah um and
this they have a [ __ ] ton of like you
know
you know foreign movies if you want to
call them that and uh and i so i really
like seeing like what other countries
are doing especially when
you see movies from countries that you
don't see a lot of horror movies
yeah we saw that thai movie was it
the pool the pool the alligator that was
outstanding
you're right there's a lot of good
movies that come from other countries
i really really like them yeah they
don't have the same studio system where
they're worried about
well we have to have this huge budget
because my brother-in-law needs
[ __ ] money and we need to hire all
these people and blah blah
and and to do this we got to flip this
movie three times what we spent it's got
to be huge
no man the story is going to [ __ ]
suffer there's some of these little
countries that go well let's just make a
cool story and make a story about a dude
that can't get out of the goddamn pool
and there's an alligator in it and for
what is that an hour and a half
yeah that alligator [ __ ] with us and
you couldn't get out of the goddamn
dude could not get out of the goddamn
pool yeah
and it was just such a simple premise
but it was so well done
yep cheap really well thought out the
whole time i'm getting frustrated i'm
[ __ ]
i mean we were like oh no
like this poor guy that's right and it
was a
super entertaining and creative movie
made out of nothing
and that's hollywood could do that for
like 10 bucks
and people would go to see it even if
the audience was small you'd make a lot
of money back
but it's not enough for these big
studios they
they got [ __ ] mansions to buy more
pools and you got to pay off all those
damn
call girl [ __ ] bills and [ __ ] you
know what i mean [ __ ] because damn
whole harems of hookers and [ __ ] they're
they're fat
bloated and spoiled and they're not very
creative anymore you know it's just
well like i said in trying to appeal to
everybody you understand
everybody yeah i mean like i said some
movies do yes the marvel movies make a
bajillion dollars and i can see like a
lot of them are for
you know foreign markets too yeah so
they have to make them like these big
like spectacle action movies because
that's going to play better overseas but
when you think about it they [ __ ]
suck
i mean a lot of them even if they don't
suck they're just not all that
memorable yeah you watch that [ __ ]
it had you had no real emotional
interplay with it
nothing offended you it was kind of cool
to watch
and as soon as we walk out of those
theaters we're like
what what happened i don't even remember
what happened i mean if you asked me
which of the marvel movies i had seen
yeah i can't tell you which one i saw
yeah i know i've seen some of them
because they're just so i kind of
remember
ant-man yeah they're just so [ __ ]
bland
the only superhero movie recently that i
saw
that i remembered and enjoyed saw it was
shazam
and i'm pretty sure they're making a
sequel to that shazam had character i
liked shazam
i remembered that one because it wasn't
just it was a character
driven yeah more than like a spectacle
yeah
and it it that was not uh then the other
one was a
verse was pretty good into the spider
verse yeah yeah yeah that was great i
like
that's pretty good i like it i like that
um what was another one that was because
that was kind of like a cool concept you
know and it was animated
so you know it had a lot of different
styles so i kind of like that it was a
lot more like artistic
i liked it um and then um
what was it bright burn that was yeah
kind of like a parallel universe [ __ ]
evil superman i liked that one um
tammy said thomas not to use the money i
sent him to pay off his call girl bills
yeah i can't no [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you got to keep that on your credit card
another goon was uh saw was uh
was recent was red sun red sun was
really good
but i'm telling you man these marvel
live action once i every one of my
joker was a [ __ ] masterpiece uh but
well like i said that was more a
character study yeah but the the
the most of that marvel [ __ ] man was
[ __ ]
bland just bland well like i said i'm
not
you know and i'm not [ __ ] on like
people that like those kind of movies or
you know i know some people are into
those and a lot of people are like
really into like the marvel cinematic
universe and they know all about the
characters and
comics and stuff so it's like a lot of
them do actually have like an emotional
connection to a lot of the characters
which that's totally that's legit it's
just i haven't watched enough of them
and i feel like there's too much focus
on it's my understanding it's all bland
jenny
well no i'm just well i think it is too
but i'm just saying i know that other
people
they saw three or four other movies that
were just as bland as the other ones and
somehow they made a connection with that
there's another generation their
standards are i think lower
if you ask me about what a good movie
was i don't think they had
i think the general viewing audience
didn't have a good background on [ __ ]
badass flicks like apocalypse now
you know that kind of [ __ ] another good
one
another superhero movie that was good
was [ __ ] venom
venom was [ __ ] really cool the only
thing that was wrong with venom is that
venom wasn't [ __ ] hard enough if that
thing was all that bad
it should have rolled them dudes heads
down the hill like a turds
like you said you know some of the [ __ ]
that venom yeah i was like
i was like yeah i want to see this now
that you brought it up i kind of want to
see that yeah
i wanted that thing to kill all kinds of
people because then it would have been
something like alien
that's what that movie really should i
would have i would have turned that up
to an r
and i think that i think venom would
have been even better as well like i
said i think that's another thing where
they're trying to appeal to everybody
because they're like well we have to
make it pg-13 so we can get all the
teenagers to come in and see it because
that's like a big chunk of their
audience and when you do that you kind
of drain all the awesome
i wouldn't worry about that [ __ ] i'd
make it r and and [ __ ] this well
they'll bootleg it or they'll [ __ ]
they'll buy the blu-ray
well what they do well what they do yeah
that's the thing that they do that stay
around for longer well they do that
alien has made made a [ __ ] ton of movie
it's been around for [ __ ] since what
is that [ __ ] 78
nine 79 yeah they do that with a lot of
horror movies where
you know particularly ones that are kind
of like geared more toward a teenager a
younger adult market
they usually will make a pg-13 version
but then when it comes out on blu-ray
they have the r
version with all the [ __ ] they cut out
of it so that's like encouraging people
to see it in the theater and then like
well if you thought it was lame then
hey here's all the good [ __ ] that we
took out of it just like just like they
did with expendables three
uh studio released uh or excuse me
theater release expendables three was
definitely not that good but i have the
blu-ray and saw the blu-ray edition of
it the r-rated edition it's
it was [ __ ] awesome expendables three
the r rated
version it was was the uh was uh was the
best out of the three it was even better
than
than expendables one well like i said i
mean i just feel like particularly
you know like i said in horror because
that's kind of like the
genre that i watched the most i do kind
of feel like
um it's horror has been a lot better
like the last 10 years it went through
like kind of a shitty spell like i think
in the late 90s to mid
2000s because everything was just kind
of like a remake or that it was just
kind of like these cash grabs or they
were just kind of lame pg-13
ghost or like [ __ ] darkness falls and
[ __ ] like that
and uh you know and i wasn't down with
that but i feel like in the last
even the last like 15 years something
like that i mean some
really really good indie horror has come
out yeah even some big bigger budget
horrors come out like i said like
one of my favorite horror movies of all
time which is hereditary came out in
[ __ ] 2018 for crystal i gotta see it
again
i was too hard on the movie i've almost
been tired at the time i was watching it
that was an incredible moment because
when smith summer came out i [ __ ]
loved it
i [ __ ] mid-summer was also fantastic
and then you said why didn't you like
hereditary it was even better
i fell asleep during hereditary well the
thing was like some people like
mid-summer better some people like that
i liked hereditary better but midsummer
was awesome i had to see it again
midsummer was awesome too they were both
awesome and in different ways and
and i like that um ari aster did
two pretty much completely different
movies and they were both awesome in
their own way
so that's kind of like hard to do i feel
like but getting back to this one mask
or skull mask what's the name of it it's
the skull colon
the mask skull the mask there you go
yeah i think like i said i think in
brazil it's called skull
the mask of the dude okay yeah
uh or any oscar or someone [ __ ] like
that i forgot
it's not a hangar yeah it's not a
brazilian word
that is a that is an indian word well
yeah that was the whole thing that it
was just kind of like they didn't even
say it was like
they didn't say it was like aztec or no
no or
you know anything like that yeah it was
like some pre-columbian [ __ ] from the
shingu
or something yeah yeah it was that kind
of thing so he wanted
somebody that was gonna go around and
tear people's hearts out yeah
and then i kind of feel like well
because they showed a few scenes where
they should after the guy with the mask
on who looked like jason
went and tore people's hearts out and
like squeeze the blood or whatever
and they only showed this thing in
close-up and it was like this
gold thing and it was like a skull at
the bottom and then it kept filling up
more and more with blood like every time
he killed somebody which was a lot of
people
um and then it would kind of go like it
like he was
filling the blood up to like unlock a
mechanism or something but they never
showed what that was i don't think
so i i kind of feel like maybe they're
setting up a sequel oh definitely
because they said there are more of
those more of the masks out there
something was happening in another
dimension but they never finished it
there's going to be more of them
evidently now it wasn't
movies like this wouldn't cost this much
to make by american standards
all right and if you have a crew
that likes making them you can get more
as long as
shutter wants to buy more i think this
is a shutter exclusive wouldn't it
or shutter original shutter i think what
they do i'm not really sure how this
works probably had a theatrical release
in brazil
probably because i'm not like in the
movie biz but what i could
what i could glean from all the stuff
that i've read is that
um you know representatives from shutter
their purchasers
and from other streaming services as
well they go around to all the festivals
and then they bid on like movies they're
like hey we want this for our streaming
service and then they have to make a
deal with that
so i think when it says shutter original
i don't think that means you can't watch
it anywhere else
i think that just means that shutter was
the one that kind of like won the
thing you know yeah or bought it for a
certain amount of money and they can
show it on their streaming service for x
amount of time before other streaming
services can happen
right i kind of think that's what the
deal is but it's a good flick
it's it's got a solid little heritage
it's uh homagine uh brazilian cinema of
the 70s
and early 80s and their cinema
originally was kind of had an italian
influence to it and this one also has an
american
influence to it to it with the kind of
like jason-esque
type slasher stuff blended into it
it's pretty neat you'll enjoy it and if
you like yeah
gore yeah check it out because the gore
in this is super fun
yeah i particularly liked all the broken
rib cages
i i enjoyed that very much i know it's a
weird thing to say
well i feel like that's a detail that a
lot of movies leave out yeah
i like seeing the bodies with these
broken ribs had a good score
had kind of a ponderous edit which is
that's that's
that that's that's in the brazilian
style which is kind of a tag
it um the acting is very good
all right very brazilian style we're
kind of like you know it's kind of
brazilian soap opera kind of like
italian where some of the
some of the characters are obviously in
there as gags
some of them are super dramatic some of
them are kind of
it's just if you unders if you've seen
brazilian television and brazilian film
you can see that a lot you know
archetypes
archetypal type characters in there in a
certain way
the brazilian archetypes louis it's good
louie asked what was the name of the
movie where four dudes go camping i
think it's norwegian
there was a movie called the ritual
where four dudes went camp was it three
dudes or four dudes now it was i think
it was a british movie but they did go
camping
i think in norway might have been that
although there was one called
uh lake bodum which was based on that
real
murder thing that took well i haven't
seen it but i keep seeing it come up on
like to be and stuff
so maybe you're talking about that maybe
you're talking about the ritual though
which was uh that was actually a really
good movie but i'm pretty sure that was
a british movie i just think it was set
in norway
because i remember it being in in
english
it wasn't it was like it was four dudes
and their friend had died
and their friend had always wanted to go
hiking in this particular area so they
said well to honor him we're going to go
do that and then
some weird supernatural [ __ ] ensued i
don't want to spoil it because it's
actually a really good movie
yeah oh i got it see i'm good i'm good
you know all right are we done yeah
we're doing that tammy says phantom 2 is
coming soon
yeah yeah i heard yeah i heard and no
need for me to say that's cause venom
got removed from marvel which made it
better
i didn't know that i guess that wasn't
marvel huh
uh i'm not the person to ask i'm not
real up on my comic book floor
that's right that's tom hardy in that i
need to buy that [ __ ] i said i was
gonna buy it after i saw it
who was that other actor that looks
almost exactly like
is it logan marshall green i don't know
that looks almost exactly like tom hardy
so he was the one in upgrade right yeah
yeah that's a good movie i want to see
that one again yeah upgrade was
fantastic yeah
that was what 2016 2017. yeah i love
that movie
but um yeah it's weird because every
time i see a movie with logan marshall
green and i'm like why aren't you tom
hardy
they look almost exactly like like i
don't know why it's just like i confuse
the two of them
there's a couple of there's a couple
actresses that i have that happen with
too but i can't remember who they are at
the moment
where it's like every time i see one of
them it's like oh it's that chick oh no
it's the timmy says she's gonna watch
this one tonight
you'll like it it's yeah it's like i
said it seems like three different
movies mashed into one
you could try it yeah you can drink or
if you like gore
yeah you should you should really love
it because the gore is super fun
i think it's entertaining entertaining
movie and and the cosmic [ __ ]
yeah when they first did that because it
was like no clue that it was going in
that direction
yeah like when the when the goth girl
kind of is like yeah i'm gonna summon
whoever like with the skull
and then all of a sudden i'm like oh
we're good we're doing this now and
tom's like oh it's going all blood
machines
[Laughter]
which yeah you know it's kind of cool
all right you ready to go yeah i'm ready
to go
we went through a whole beer well you
went through that it's actually a double
it's actually two beers because it's a
bottle of guinness and a bottle of
wicked grove yeah with a little magnet
try to try it man it's called black
velvet i got corrected
but it's been so long since i had it
snake bite was the one i think it was uh
that was a cider and um some kind of
like a
like a like a red beer or something
remember what it was it was a different
kind of beer yeah the black velvet
good [ __ ] fourth year down set just
mentioned i wanted to mention this
because uh we're talking about logo
marshall green
he said he was in a movie called the
invitation that's pretty good i'm
actually going gonna do a flickers of
fear
on that but is it this week or it's
probably not this week but next week
because i've seen that movie a couple of
times and that movie is so good and i
[ __ ] recommend it to everybody it's
on netflix
um it's like a psychological horror and
uh i'm gonna try to talk about it on the
show but it's like
if if you've seen it like watch it but
if you haven't seen it don't read
anything about it
just like watch it and not know where
it's going because i didn't know where
it was going
it's like so much better because i was
just at the end i was like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it was that old kind of situation but
yeah it's uh i think it came out in
2015.
so i'm gonna be reviewing that one in a
week or two all right
so we are going to knock off for the day
it's tuesday right
yeah so tomorrow night is our drunken
side tracks live
streaming those bottles over here hand
me those bottles yeah today is not
drunken
today is not today is just like mildly
it's mildly inebriated tomorrow night is
gonna be
okay drunken probably yeah i mean i hope
not
unless i fall asleep on the show we'll
see how it goes but yeah tomorrow
night's the sidetrack show so we'll see
you guys tomorrow at 5 p.m eastern
standard time
thanks you guys for dropping by thanks
for super chats have a good rest of your
day
and we will see you guys tomorrow
evening bye